also warum ist das denn so dass die cdu
immer weiblicher wird also soler von der
leyen wie ronald pofalla
[Musik]
die cdu männer geben ein bild ab dass
selbst alice schwarzer die tränen in die
augen treibt ich bin hier und suche den
letzten mann der cdu um ihm dafür zu
verleihen
die goldenen eier was passiert
eigentlich auf dem parteitag die frauen
treiben sich auf eine zigarren cognac
reden über politik und die männer
wünschen auf euch durch oder wir wieder
auf sie kommen auch gut in die ecken
rein
mir wurde gesagt nimmt ein wichtiger
mann in der cdu kritisch denn gestern
den bundesvorstand gewählt worden
vorteil wissen was ich hab das geht ich
nach drei ist klassischer welcher und
club
[Musik]
frau merkel eine kurze frage eine frage
keine frage jetzt wenn die männer hier
unterdrückt
wie bewerten sie die männer der cdu auf
einer männlichkeit gala von 117 117
freuen
maximal 44 ist das schöne frau hat auch
schöne frau sind ja aber es gibt noch
genug sage meine einer steht ja vorhin
noch an jetzt menschen immer weiter wird
also sein wie ronald pofalla
wir suchen ja den letzten mann endet für
die uhr nicht finde sie winter und typ
sind noch ein echter kerl und deswegen
möchten wir ihnen ein folgendes
verleihen
die goldene eier
ich konnte meine eier in die hände von
völker wo wir legen
damit gebe ich gewählt und zurück nach
köln
[Musik]